secondo la National sleep Foundation la
persona media sogna da 4 a Se volte per
notte e ogni sogno dura circa dai 20 ai
30 minuti quindi se facciamo una media
ci sono
1460 sogni all'anno per un totale di
29.200 minuti
e come cazzo è possibile che io me ne
ricordi due massimo tre
all'anno ho iniziato a chiedere alle
persone che mi circondano una semplice
domanda Tu te li ricordi i sogni che fai
quasi tutti Sì quasi tutti solo la
mattina Quindi per un paio d'ore tranne
due che mi sono rimasti particolarmente
impressi questo perché io non riesco è
sempre stato così da 35 anni di vita
solo due tre massimo quattro volte
all'anno io riesco a ricordare i sogni
che faccio e basta e tra l'altro quei
pochi sono anche molto poco interessanti
rispetto a quelli che mi racconta la
gente mai una volta che io voli sulle
strade di New York o che combatta un
drago nei cieli della terra di mezzo no
è sempre qualcosa di super generico papà
era nera che in quel periodo e ho
sognato che ero mano nella mano con lui
io ero più piccolina ed eravamo in una
strada tra l'altro nella nostra zona di
Torino però è era Baghdad non era Torino
da piccolo papà e Karim scherzavano
sempre sul fatto che mi Cioè mi
avrebbero abbandonato vicino ai bidoni
che così è stato praticamente stavano
bombardando e papà mi lascia vicino al
bidone e io piangevo piangevo Secondo me
più che altro per il bidone non tanto
quanto per i bombardamenti E perché mi
avete terrorizzato quando ero piccola
che mi avreste abbandonato e quindi
certo E tutto questo che sto portando
avanti tutto questo ambaradan è nato da
un podcast un giorno su Instagram vengo
taggato in un episodio di Dream Catcher
il podcast di Davide Grando che racconta
tutti i sogni che fa durante la notte
sono Davide Grando e vi condurro la
scoperta del mio mondo nirico e in
alcuni di questi ci sono io in quel
periodo Karim stava lavorando con un
altro canale come autore e per questo
canale qui aveva scritto un monologo il
tutto è girato nel mio bagno ed Ho
subito pensato Due cose uno che gran
figata di idea è quella del podcast due
cazzo giusto che io non sogno mai o
meglio non ricordo i sogni che faccio
perché sognare sogniamo tutti quindi
questo podcast ha dato il via ad un
viaggio per capire e scoprire come mai
io non riesca a ricordarmi Ho appena
finito di vedere l'episodio sui sogni
della mente In poche parole la serie su
Netflix super interessante Tra l'altro
ve lo consiglio ed è un episodio che
dura una ventina di minuti dove spiega
proprio Cosa sono i sogni ha parlato
della fase REM notturna che è quella
dove il cervello si attiva per farci
vedere eh e percepire quelle immagini
REM Tra l'altro vuol dire Rapid Eye
movement perché mentre tutto il nostro
corpo è disattivato gli occhi sono
l'unica parte Durante la fase REM che è
attiva Infatti spiegava che Eh se tu
guardi delle cose che vanno a destra e a
sinistra durante i sogni o delle cose in
alto e in basso gli occhi si muovono di
conseguenza molto interessante però un
professore ha detto una cosa particolare
ha detto se vuoi essere sicuro di
ricordarti i tuoi sogni svegliati
Durante la fase REM cioè proprio mentre
stai sognando se tu ti svegli ti ricordi
l'ultima porzione che poi è quello che
si ricordano tutti quanti e ha detto di
andare a dormire bevendo tre bicchieri
d'acqua così sei obbligato a a a
svegliarti per andare a pisciare Ma
potrò dovre dover andare a pisciare per
ricordarmi I sogni non c'è un metodo
meno scemo Ora vado a dormire questa è
la prima notte che faccio monitorata per
il video ma la faccio normale senza test
senza nessun tipo di di prova di di
esperimento per vedere se riesco a a
sognare ho bevuto mezza bottiglia
d'acqua nella speranza di riuscire a
fare la pipì durante la fase REM Spero
non prima Spero non dopo
Buonanotte sono le 6:30 e mi sono
svegliato per andare in bagno ma non mi
ricordo il sogno però ho quella
sensazione orrenda di aver interrotto
qualcosa aver interrotto Il mio cervello
elaborare qualcosa però non mi ricordo
assolutamente nulla anche se non è
ancora scientificamente chiaro perché
sogniamo sappiamo per certo che il sogno
si verifica durante questo momento della
notte nella fase REM avvengono rapidi
movimenti oculari e le onde celebrali
assomigliano quelle presenti nello stato
di Veglia quindi è come se di notte il
cervello si svegliasse per i fatti
propri Facendoci vedere e sentire e
percepire cose come se fossimo svegli
studiare i sogni è come comprare
qualcosa di nuovo nella tua vita prima
non te ne accorgevi Ma adesso lo vedi
ovunque in ogni canzone In ogni film in
ogni telefilm in ogni libro in ogni
racconto in ogni videogioco c'è sempre
il momento sogno Perché i sogni fanno
parte del processo creativo praticamente
da quando Esiste l'uomo e non solo
l'uomo perché si è scoperto negli anni
che anche un sacco di animali sognano e
la cosa interessante è quella che dicevo
prima non si sa a livello scientifico
esattamente cosa siano i sogni perché
l'evoluzione ha deciso di utilizzare
tantissima energia per sognare la
risposta semplice non lo sappiamo la
risposta lunga non sappiamo a cosa
servano i sogni in senso stretto ma
sappiamo A cosa serve la fase REM Quella
in cui sogniamo per dire lo psicologo
goldman Paragona l'attività onirica ad
una specie di pulizia mentale la sua
teoria afferma che mediante l'atto del
sognare il cervello Seleziona quali
informazioni conviene conservare e quali
dimenticare Freud invece nella sua
classica ottica psicoanalitica diceva
che sognare serve a dare voce alle
pulsioni più intime che durante il
giorno vengono bloccate dalla coscienza
tu hai sognato di menare un bambino di
sparare un bambino eh Erica Freud dice
Tu lo vuoi fare Io li ho fatti a pezzi
Tu li hai fatti a pezzi e nascosti
nascosti fugge mamma mia in camera da
letto ho uno di quei proiettori che
proiettano l'intero Universo con le
stelle non so se mi possa servire per
per sognare ma non credo proprio e
quindi vediamo subito oggi con in questo
video Come ricordarsi sogni e come
ritornare a sognare di nuovo se siete
convinti che non Sognate state a
guardare perché sicuramente i consigli
che sto per condividere con voi vi
aiuteranno per approfondire questo
argomento Ho comprato dei libri che mi
facessero capire meglio il funzionamento
del cervello durante i sogni e magari
imparare qualche tecnica mnemonica per
poterli ricordare ve li metto anche in
descrizione Se volete guida i sogni
imparare a usare i sogni per risvegliare
la coscienza e il magico potere dei
sogni e la loro interpretazione della
dottoressa Elisa Sergi che ho
intervistato la memoria va allenata
specialmente quando viene risvegliata
dopo il nostro sonno per ricordare i
sogni devi Rere immobile nello Stato in
cui sei appena ti alzi soprattutto devi
rimanere con la testa devi fare un
esercizio mentale rimanere con la testa
esattamente dove sei Piano piano
emergeranno I ricordi è un muscolo e va
allenato Buongiorno quando mi sveglio
percepisco di aver interrotto qualcosa
però poi più mi sforzo di capire cosa
stessi sognando e meno mi ricordo tanto
che poi arrivo a dire ma ero veramente
in piedi ero veramente dentro un camion
e poi svanisce tutto quanto talvolta le
persone spiccatamente razionali fanno
maggior fatica ad imprimersi alla
memoria ai sogni persone spiccatamente
razionali presente cioè il mio essere
razionale nella vita fa in modo che il
mio cervello Lavori anche di notte per
censurare e rimuovere le cose inutili i
contenuti inconsci desideri repressi
bisogni negati tutta roba che fa fatica
ad emergere per questo motivo è
incredibile sono Terminator sei una
persona tristissima e tu sei brutta Vedi
un attimo fai così vedi un
attimo il mio sonno parla molto chiaro
Guarda ho un app qui che lo dimostra
quando racconto questa cosa qua la gente
mi prende per un alieno Ok io vado a
dormire più o meno sempre allo stesso
orario da tantissimi anni Chiudo gli
occhi e li riapro che sono le 7:00 del
mattino Questa dovrebbe essere la norma
Ma guarda caso lo strano sono io Eh
certo sono stato
7,83 3 ore a letto ok sveglio 6 minuti
probabilmente 3 la sera per
addormentarmi e 3:00 al mattino per
alzarmi dal letto 6 minuti su quasi 8
ore questo è sleep monitor Se volete
saperlo c'è un'altra app che io mi
ricordo che avevo usato tanti anni fa
che si chiama parlare nel sonno che è
l'app che ti registra ogni volta che tu
parli nel sonno ridi russi eccetera
eccetera e puoi condividere questi audio
con il resto della community che usa
l'app Indovinate qual è la clip che la
gente condivide di più In questa
app la cosa bella del sogno è che non
hanno regola ci sono pazienti che mi
dicono dei sogni che sono proprio
Sembrano dei film no razionali dove c'è
una trama e invece altri pazienti tra i
quali io peraltro che si sogna delle
robe assurde Cioè veramente che anche
solo raccontarle è difficilissimo per
non farmi deprimere da queste
informazioni ho deciso di fare di tutto
per poter spingere il mio cervello a
ricordare i
sogni nel libro della guida dei sogni
c'è un un capitolo per favorire i sogni
cioè come riuscire a aiutare il tuo
cervello e il tuo corpo a sognare e c'è
anche il tutorial su come preparare la
tisana della sera alla passiflora E
allora siamo andati alla ricerca in
un'erboristeria della pass Flora della
Melissa del Luppolo insomma per fare
questo infuso però mi ha dato
un'alternativa molto molto valida mi ha
dato questa tisana che si chiama vir
relax della viropa che tra gli
ingredienti ha la pasiflora la Melissa
la camomilla la valeriana il luppolo la
lavanda ha tutto quello che mi serve la
proprietaria mi ha anche raccontato che
questa la vendeva durante il periodo del
covid perché la gente arrivava coi nervi
tesi diceva Non riesco a dormire dammi
qualcosa e lei sganciava questa bomba
atomica Cosa stai sognando Oh cazzo di
nuovo l'ho perso non mi
ricordo non mi
ricordo una delle mie paure più grandi è
se dovessi per sbaglio mettere troppo
sotto stress Il mio cervello e lui come
risposta difensiva rispondesse con la
paralisi del sonno tu ti ricordi i sogni
che fai Io me li ricordo solo perché me
li segno si chiamano sogno e data in cui
l'ho fatto in cui mi scrivo più o meno i
punti salienti Tu sei la persona che mi
ha introdotto nel mondo della paralisi
del sonno Grazie mille bellego C di che
sei anche apposto me l'hai raccontato
tanto tempo fa quando ci siamo ma tanti
anni fa e mi hai traumatizzato
completamente paralisi del sonno Intanto
è un termine molto grande che fa anche
molta impressione io quindi non essendo
medico non so quanto utilizzarlo però è
effettivamente quello che mi è capitato
dura pochi minuti però in quegli attimi
in cui il tuo cervello è sveglio ma il
tuo corpo no E tua mamma ti sta
chiamando Tu non riesci ad alzarti dici
cazzo starò qui tutta la vita sono morto
e questa la morte non lo so Il brutto
della paralisi del sonno è che prende
fortemente controllo del cervello Cioè
ti prende proprio lì e quindi ti fa
anche provare sensazioni che
teoricamente non ci sono Mi è capitato
una notte di pensare di svegliarmi di
sentire fisicamente di fianco a me
qualcuno che si siede sul mio letto con
la sensazione proprio delle coperte e
del peso che sposta il letto attorno a
me perché alla fine è un una
sottocategoria credo degli incubi e fa
fa quello che deve fare un incubo cioè
spaventarti sto andando a dormire un'ora
dopo circa il mio orario
quindi sono l' 1:30 ma mi sveglierò
Comunque alle 7:00 perché voglio forzare
lo svegliarmi durante la fase REM o
comunque durante un sogno pesante e
vediamo cosa
succede Come dicevamo prima i sogni si
trovano ovunque nel mondo creativo
Sembra incredibile ma lovecraft ha
sognato alcune delle storie che ha
scritto Mary Shelley fu ispirata da un
sogno quando scrisse Frankenstein
Salvador da lì Santo cielo Salvador da
lì ha rappresentato le i suoi sogni più
strani nelle sue opere più famose e
andando a ripescare nella mia memoria ci
sono due cose ambientate nel mondo
onirico che sono state molto importanti
per la mia vita una in un modo una
nell'altro adesso se me lo fai trovare
Eccolo qua LSD Dream Emulator nel 1998
per la prima PlayStation uscì questo
simulatore barra emulatore di sogni e tu
in questo gioco viaggiavi e Camminavi
tra vari tipi di sogno Tra l'altro
questi sogni erano tratti da un diario
dei sogni che teneva uno degli
sviluppatori e questo è uno degli esempi
che tenendo traccia dei tuoi sogni può
portare ad un lavoro creativo L'altro
invece Eccolo qua hai mai sognato
quest'uomo nel 2008 appare online un
sito
www.dan.org ma non solo per strada nella
vita vera In alcune zone iniziano ad
essere attaccati questi volantini ogni
notte in giro per il mondo migliaia di
persone vedono questa faccia nei loro
sogni Se quest'uomo appare nei tuoi
sogni contattaci Ecco questa storia ha
fatto partire delle cospirazioni
gigantesche delle leggende metropolitane
su internet incredibili in realtà era
soltanto un diciamo chiamiamolo
esperimento sociale che però si è
scoperto che migliaia di persone
contattarono il sito dicendo di aver
sognato quell'uomo quell'uomo che non
esiste questo perché anche solo
guardando un'immagine le persone hanno
influenzato Il loro cervello nel sognare
una cosa che in realtà non c'è uno
studio sui sogni coordinato dalla
dottoressa mednick effettuato
all'Università di San Diego metti in
evidenza i maggiori picchi di creatività
che si rilevano fra i sognatori queste
scoperte confermano che i sogni
favoriscono la creatività favoriscono
l'associazione di immagini
l'elaborazione di concetti e la
risoluzione di problemi perché avendo un
vissuto di sofferenza di disagio è molto
forte no E quindi chi la sperimenta a
livello proprio sopra soglia dico io e
pensa a quanto materiale nell'inconscio
in questo buco nero che c'è cioè Cioè
strabordante quindi sono sogni ricchi di
emotività Ciao sono Luna soffro di ansia
e depressione ed è tutto
vero Quindi tu ti ricordi i sogni che
fai sì e me li ricordo quasi tutti e
anche molto molto molto vividi e molto
violenti la maggior parte delle volte
quindi tipo mi ricordo le sensazioni mi
ricordo gli odori mi ricordo il tatto mi
ricordo l'odore del sangue mi ricordo
tante cose brute brutte
Sì io mi ritrovo molto spesso a
combattere con le mie idee il blocco
dello scrittore il cosiddetto blocco
dello scrittore capita a tutti ma ci
sono periodi della mia vita in cui io
cammino e vivo la vita di tutti i giorni
con un enorme foglio bianco stampato
sulla faccia che nonostante io provi a
spremere il mio cervello per far uscire
qualche idea decente da presentare al
canale non si riempie non si riempie mai
e rimane lì tutto il tempo quindi
sentirsi in difetto per non sognare
potrebbe non essere così
sbagliato ero seduto in un
prato ero seduto in un prato è l'unica
cosa che mi ricordo l'unica immagine che
ho impressa nella memoria vedo
chiaramente l'erba muoversi e gli alberi
muoversi
eh per credo perché sto giocando a delen
Ring in questo periodo In elden Ring
l'erbe e gli alberi sono costantemente
mossi dal vento però ero seduto in un
prato e non mi ricordo neanche se stessi
facendo qualcosa mi ricordo solo quello
e
è un passo avanti Ma così piccolo che
non so neanche se segnarlo nel libro se
sprecare una pagina per segnare questa
cosa qui Eccomi qua il cervellone
razionale che mi fa sognare
letteralmente il nulla e per l'occasione
nella speranza di riuscire a sognare ho
comprato la scatola dei sogni 60 carte
per decifrare l' inconscio Praticamente
sono carte che ti permettono di capire e
di dare un significato al sogno che hai
fatto Eccolo qua alberi montagne e
giardini di solito le foreste
simboleggiano l'ignoto e potrebbero
rappresentare un senso di confusione e
smarrimento Sarò sincero ha pesato tanto
questa cosa in queste settimane in
questo mese di ricerche perché non so
come fare ma per non deprimermi del
tutto e non iniziare a piangere in video
ho deciso di concludere tutta questa
storia esattamente come è iniziata come
uno strambo loop sono Davide Grand e ho
un po' podcast sui sogni e te li ricordi
tutti bene o male Sì ti odio tu
probabilmente non lo sai ma quei tuoi
podcast hanno
innestato Questo video questo intero
video cosa ho creato ti ricordi i sogni
che fai Sì decisamente sì come fai a
ricordarti più di un sogno cioè come fai
a capire quando un sogno finisce un
sogno Inizia tu puoi iniziare sognando a
Topolino per finire a sognare
Hitler perché è il cervello ti crea
questi viaggioni incredibili tra un
sogno e l'altro succede la qualunque
quindi non è così difficile riuscire a
collegare da uno all'altro Come fai a
capire quando un sogno inizia e un sogno
finisce come te lo spiego uno che non
sogna l'effetto inception di svegliarsi
da un sogno mi è capitato con più
inception fino a tre volte e mi è
capitato anche di Ok sto sognando e mi
sveglio Ok Anche questo è un sogno e mi
sveglio e poi non inizio a Cioè a un
certo punto dici sto sognando veramente
cioè sono sveglio sto sognando non
capisci più nulla e lì Stai ancora
sognando e poi veramente ti svegli io
sto provando un'invidia che tu non hai
idea per questa cosa Cosa ridi tu cosa
ridi hai la sveglia tu Eh sì ho una
sveglia la fai sentire e Samuele
Bersani l'altro giorno mi è capitato che
il corriere mi suonasse io ero nel mezzo
della mia fase REM e mi ha suonato
talmente forte quel citofono che in
automatico mi ha fatto dimenticare tutto
quello che avevo sognato Ma parliamo dei
Sogni lucidi e Sogni lucidi Io mi
ricordo sogni di quando avrei avuto 6-7
anni e mi ricordo anche i miei Primi
Sogni lucidi che saranno tipo quando
avrò avuto 12 anni così quindi 15 anni
fa comunque e mi ricordo che ero in
questo paesaggio però sai cosa manca la
neve schiocco le dita No ti prego cosa
ti ti giuro da creare persone palazzi
volare quando tu nei tuoi sogni lucidi
riesci a volare hai Rus Sei riuscito a
raggiungere il massimo dell'ambizione
nei Sogni lucidi più che quello non puoi
fare zio mio e io non posso fare niente
neanche quelli stupidi miei in uno dei
tuoi sogni Dove hai sognato me Io scrivo
per un altro canale che sarebbe una cosa
tra l'altro da da provare ed eravamo in
bagno nel bagno di casa sua n bagno di
casa sua spoiler il tutto è girato nel
mio bagno tu eri in piedi io ero in
piedi stavi parlando alla telecamera Ti
lascio la telecamera Sì stavo parlando
la telecamera Poi poi a un certo punto
proprio inizi a menare contro il bagno
spacchi tutto ma Karim Quello era il mio
di bagno poi rimonto tutto perché riesco
effettivamente a rimettere tutti a posto
dico Ok son anche un bravo idraulico
scarico troppo funzion funzion
nulla ho fatto Recentemente un sondaggio
su Instagram questo qua e volevo
ringraziarvi perché avete risposto quasi
in un centinaio di migliaio di persone
Ma questo video lo voglio
dedicare a quel
7% Questo video mi ha dato l'aggancio
perfetto per Nord VPN vuoi fare sonni
tranquilli vuoi avere sogni d'oro Nord
VPN è la soluzione per te Chissà se me
lo Approvano fatto dal letto Nord VPN ti
fa dormire sonni tranquilli perché
cripta della tua connessione quando ti
colleghi ad una rete pubblica in modo da
evitare di avere incubi la notte Poi
puoi anche cambiare l'IP del tuo paese
d'origine connettendoti a quello di un
altro paese per cercare magari offerte
migliori per quanto riguarda i libri sul
Come sognare e attivando la threat
Protection non avrete più paralisi del
sonno pop-up invasivi e malware dai siti
Mi raccomando usufruite delle offerte
con il codice sconto Yotobi
Buonanotte
h